my favorite ways to get a prospect to  confront a decision when they say I need  to think about it is this all you have  to ask back is no problem do you need  two or three days or two or three months  to think about it the point is you want  to exaggerate the time frame based on  what you sell by a huge amount so much  that they look at you look at you weird  and you say right of course at the end  of the day you're going to make a  decision based on these three things so  we might as well just make it today and  if you're curious what those three  things are is one am I the person you  want to do business with two do you  believe the product's gonna work and  three is this the company that you  believe in that you think that we stand  by our promises